so uh before i jump into talking about
some specifics uh i like asking
everybody um a first curveball question
um if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done what is the
first thing you want them watching and
why
you know there's a movie that i did uh
many years ago called the dying gall
g-a-u-l
i'm going to say that one just because
uh
i don't know it was kind of an
experience that wasn't like this one but
it had his own
intense intensity
and uh not many people have seen it
i like that answer um so jumping into
why i get to talk to you today uh i
there's so many things to love about
this film but the thing that i think i
love the most is that it talks about
things that you talk about in private
with people that never get put out into
the world you know it's the it's the
whispers between people and yet it's you
know that's the focus of the film um can
you sort of talk about that aspect that
it's dealing with such
you know things that everyone deals with
but never gets talked about
well i think you know
there's
there's two things there's the fantasy
life
that we all
imagine that we're leading or hope to be
leading
that is um
kind of a utopian
thing right like i want to be the best
parent and the best actor
and the whatever your
personal ambition is and
in terms of
who you are
right and then there's the actuality of
how you're living and i think the closer
we get to
where we're actually at rather than
where we would like to be
the better things will go and i think
that this movie is really about
um
somebody who's not living her best life
this is she's sacrificed too much
in terms of her
own desires and ambitions and um
if she doesn't break out i mean i i
think it's really wild in this movie
that you're sort of i find myself
rooting for her to do something that is
going to hurt other people
it's actually an interesting point that
i hadn't thought about
um
uh what is it like playing
the
uh catalyst for change for jesse's
character and also being like this
object of desire
oh it's great if people want to cast me
as the object of desire i i'm all for it
i'll do it any anytime
um
it was nice to play
the character but also you know there's
an element of him in there that i was
really interested in which was
the part of him that's missing out on
something you know we frequently think
of these people that are like the
you know not the husband or wife but the
satellite person the third wheel the the
person that is uh
that they're having the affair with is
having it good or being lucky or
you know they he doesn't have kids and
he's just going around sleeping with
different people
and i think like in the end he's left
kind of hollow
he's not wanting to
continue this thing he's not happy with
the way she's talking with her children
because he's not a part of that it's
like that's her real life and he's in
the pretend life
so it was interesting thinking about him
with some amount of um compassion
what is it actually like i can't imagine
this what i'm about to ask you but what
is it like being directed by your wife
when you're filming a love scene
you know a lot of the thing with these
love scenes
is they're very technical you know it's
not like
it is not the same as it is in life
sure um
it's it's more like dancing
than it is like anything you know that's
what it
feels like so you you're trying to get
in anyone's hands when your wife's doing
it
it's a slightly easier because i felt
like it made it easier for jesse
like jesse
he knows she's in safe hands my wife
doesn't want me to have like some
real sex with jessie or something like
that or even like
um
to fall in love with her or something so
it's it's it feels like a very safe
environment is what i would say and it's
very technical all that stuff
uh i am actually a very big fan of your
work and i love learning about the way
actors um prepare for scenes so
hypothetically if you're filming
something on like a monday it's very
emotional it's very dramatic you know
it's a big scene how early on are you
actually breaking down how you want to
play that scene you know what i mean
like can you sort of take me through
your process a little bit
i mean if a scene on the page says like
he has his big cathartic moment and now
he sees the light sort of thing
or the baby's dead or something like
that something that you know is gonna is
gonna challenge you as an actor
yeah i the thing i don't
prepare in the way that you're talking
about
very much for something that's just
emotional
um the thing that i do a lot of
preparation for
is like
giving a lecture
where my i'm playing someone who has to
know a lot about something um giving the
uh
the final speech in a courtroom trial
before the jury and i'm the lawyer
and i have to like explain why they need
to decide that sort of thing requires a
lot more
homework
in a scene that has got an emotional
value that it's really mostly about that
i i try to show up and relax and
walk in without a lot in my mind
that's interesting and it's a completely
different answer than i've heard from
other people yet i completely understand
it and it makes
it makes total sense and i always tell
myself
you don't have to do anything like if
the scene says that the baby is dead
if my reaction is like yours face right
now
people will project that on to me
there is no specific reaction to the
most tragic events in life
that we all know to expect because very
few of us have been through them and
those of us who have
know that sometimes people laugh
randomly
sometimes sometimes people get into a
coughing fit sometimes people
just sit there
i mean it's uh
you can really take the onus off of
yourself as an actor when it says
the baby's dead
um i i
yeah
as i said
it's
i'm look i like talking about this
because i every time i learn something
new you know it's really cool um you got
you filmed this movie during the heart
of covid and you were on an island in
greece um what is it actual what was it
like making a film that's obviously on a
budget
in the middle of the pandemic what can
you sort of take me behind the scenes
the budget had to get slightly larger
because
a huge amount of money needed to be
spent
to keep people there for 14 days in
quarantine that we're only working for
three or four
um to cover test everyone three or four
times a week to hire an epidemiologist
all of that stuff i mean there was um
that's all added tons of money to to
filming so that was difficult
um
but greece was just
a perfect place to make it both in terms
of like the number of covid cases at the
time
but also because there's a great history
of filmmaking there and there were many
capable people
we had a very international group of
people so it was like
felt close to home to everyone except
maybe us
um you know very british
cast and english uh french dp
israeli producers i mean we were
it was coming from everywhere
i have to stop there i'm just gonna say
again congrats on the movie and as i
told your wife i hope she's making
something again soon she's really
talented thank you so much for your time